Last night, I congratulated Donald Trump...
...and offered to work with him on behalf of our country.
I hope that he will be a successful president for all Americans.
This is not the outcome we wanted or we worked so hard for...
...and I'm sorry that we did not win this election...
...for the values we share and the vision we hold for our country.
But I feel pride and gratitude for this wonderful campaign that we built together,...
...this vast, diverse, creative, unruly, energized campaign.
You represent the best of America...
...and being your candidate has been one of the greatest honors of my life.
This is painful, and it will be for a long time,...
...but I want you to remember this:...
...our campaign was never about one person or even one election.
It was about the country we love...
...and about building an America that's hopeful, inclusive and big-hearted.
We have seen that our nation is more deeply divided than we thought,...
...but I still believe in America and I always will.
Finally, I am so grateful for our country and for all it has given to me.
I count my blessings every single day that I am an American...
...and I still believe, as deeply as I ever have,...
...that if we stand together and work together with respect for our differences,...
...strength in our convictions and love for this nation,...
...our best days are still ahead of us.